bonjour à tout le monde bonjour yves
bussy et bonjour rate mon plaisir
bonjour bertrand caruge bonjour il bûche
et puis bonjour à tous les auditeurs
bienvenue dans notre studio ralph
montplaisir maire de case-pilote soutien
d' emmanuel macron à l'élection
présidentielle donc sympathisants au
moins de la république en mars et
peut-être même à l'heure où on parle
etes-vous le le référent de la
république en marchant en martinique
ralph montplaisir mettait d'abord je
vais remettre les choses dans l'ordre
je n'ai pas voté emmanuel macron
volontairement je n'ai pas bien sûr pas
voter le pen mais je ne savais pas à
quoi m'attendre j'ai très rapidement
ce ressenti le besoin de soutenir ce
gouvernement et ce président qui pour
moi est l image de ce que ce dont nous
avions besoin
nous avions besoin de quelqu'un qui a
qui prennent les risques de d'aller
jusqu'au bout de mettre en oeuvre ce
dont parlait tout le monde de tous les
bords politiques depuis une trentaine
d'années ce qui ad'ailleurs déstabiliser
un peu les autres puisqu'il fait ce que
les autres disait qu'il fallait faire
mais qui ne sait pas faire
donc c'est pour ça que je les ai
soutenus et pas pardon que je me suis
rapproché du mouvement et que j'ai été
le premier même inscrit attendez vous
dit pas refaire les résidentiels mais au
deuxième tour vous n'avez pas voté
emmanuel macron face à marine le pen
je n'ai voté ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre mon épouse a voté macron enjeux
voté blanc mais j'ai mes vous êtes vite
rallié on je me suis rallié j'ai été le
premier maire ici à m'inscrire à la
république en marche
on veut être allé à paris avoir expliqué
que je n'avais pas voté pour emmanuel
macron parce que c'est mon caractère je
dis les choses que je fais ou que j'ai
fait ou je ferme ma bouche mais je leur
ai tout de suite dit que je voulais
soutenir ce gouvernement ce que je fais
depuis ce depuis que ce jour là
depuis ce jour là alors la république en
mars est sorti vainqueur ici en
martinique des dernières élections
européennes alors d'une courte tête 1
800 voix d'écart avec le rassemblement
national
c'est assez peu finalement bon c'est
vrai que c'est un scrutin un peu
particulier les élections européennes
bon mais râle font plaisir cette
relative victoire qui peut qui doit même
la revendiquer ici en martinique le
candidat tête de liste aux élections
européennes en l'occurrence donc max
orville où les mères qui sont des
soutiens ou des sympathisants de la
république en marche
donc vous donc mais alors il quelques
autres comme christian raphaël justin
pamphile par exemple absolument d'abord
il faut ne faut pas mettre de côté la
valeur de l'homme max orville est un
homme de qualité
effectivement c'est à lui qui est ici en
martinique était le candidat si je peux
utiliser ce terme
cependant il n'y a pas de petites
victoires au mans j'ai gagné ma première
élection à quinze pilotes au premier
tour j'avais une voix de plus une voix
de plus que le maire qui était en place
et j'étais devant avec une voix donc il
n'ya pas de petites victoires il ya que
de grandes victoires et il n'y a pas de
petites défaites il n'y a que des
défaites donc où de grandes défaites il
n'y en a pas il ya que des défaites donc
moins je vous dirais que oui nous avons
gagné cette élection ici en martinique
nous en sommes fiers et c'est le travail
de l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui en
tant que maire ou autres soutiennent ce
gouvernement et il y en a beaucoup de
petits ne sont pas forcément inscrits à
la république en marche mais qui
soutiennent j'en veux pour preuve mon
ami de grandes bières qui est qui a été
celui qui a eu le plus gros pourcentage
de voix en faveur de
le gouvernement laïc en marche et moi
j'étais le deuxième à avoir le plus gros
pourcentage alors il ya schelcher aussi
où la république en mars est sorti en
tête
oui mais moi je suis avant un
pourcentage non c'est important alors
parce que je suis un maire républicain
manche et ma population m'a suivi et je
tiens appuyer sur ça donc vous entendez
vous aussi revendiqué ce résultat aux
élections européennes en martinique
ah bah écoutez si je le revendique ai
pas je serai un traiteur n'avait
finalement pas si couillaud rija alors
oui je le revendique
oui oui alors c'est important parce que
en ce moment justement sont en train
d'être déterminée lé les investitures
qui vont être attribuées par la
république en marche pour les prochaines
élections municipales
une semaine après les résultats des
élections européennes la république en
mars donc à installer c'était le 3 juin
sa commission d'investiture en vue des
prochaines municipales
est-ce que vous allez vous inscrire dans
sa est ce que vous pouvez dire ce matin
que vous-même officiellement vous
demandez à avoir l'investiture de la
république en marche si jamais vous
décidiez de vous présenter aux élections
municipales de vous représenter bien
cher désir à case-pilote bien sûr je me
représente
et bien sûr que je revendique d'office
de représenter la république en manche
sur ma commune
le contraire aurait été vraiment dommage
et pas explicite
effectivement la république en manche
est en train de s'organiser dans tous
les sens du terme
il y a eu récemment la nomination d'une
référente qui je pense est très occupé à
se mettre en place et à s'organiser
alors on va revenir sur cette décision
mais comme vous dites qu'il ya une
nouvelle référence qui a été installée
suite au départ de saarloos gressier ici
en martinique
la structuration elle n'est pas facile
de la république en marche ici en
martinique alors où en est on est est ce
que vous même vous vous mêlez de ce à
quoi de cette affaire là juste
l'organisation largeur et qu'en mars ici
j'ai toujours eu
comme principe que deux capitaines trois
capitaines dans un bateau le bateau
coule
le capitaine aujourd'hui c'est la
référence de la public la république en
manche
je n'étais pas candidat d'ailleurs à ce
poste et je n'ai pas de volonté
d'occuper ce poste et il a été il y a eu
un flottement il ya eu un moment
d'attentes et puis finalement paris a
organisé les choses a choisi une
référente
mais de toutes les façons il y à des
évolutions en cours de façon globale sur
la référente sur le vide en marche
globalement il va avoir quelque chose
semble-t-il qui sera un choix look à
chaque chaque dans chaque endroit ce
seront les soutiens qu'ils voteront
choisiront celles ou ceux qui conduiront
le mouvement alors justement à
case-pilote est ce qu'il y a des
velléités de candidature après ces
résultats
ce bon résultat finalement vous avez eu
aux élections européennes vous le
rappeliez tout à l'heure dans dans la
commune
alors c'est un vous collectif vous le
maire mais voilà d'une manière générale
mais est ce que certains pourraient à
partir de ce résultat se dire j'ai
peut-être des chances moitié d'aller à
case-pilote et puis de demander aussi
l'investiture
bah écoutez ce serait l'endroit après
tout mais mais je vais vous dire quelque
chose nous avons la chance de vivre dans
une démocratie et tout le monde est
libre de faire ce qu'il ce qu'il veut un
personne ne peut vous empêcher ou r d
dans la rue tous les samedis alléger les
jeunes
qui manifestent on les empêche pas de
manifester non s'il ya des gens qui sont
intéressés qui sont candidats ils seront
candidats
s'il ya des gens qui souhaitent avoir
l'investiture ils le diront après tout
ils ont réparé max orville par exemple
qui lui a un moment étaient présents
politique à case-pilote on se souvient
il était non c'est vrai que je cherchais
reka ce pilote il s'est partagé entre
les deux communes mais l'occasion de se
présenter à des élections
oui mais vous savez je pense que max
orville qui on le rappelle et du modem
lui seul un parti allié avec la
république en marche
tout à fait et max orville est sûre
celle cher aujourd'hui il est en plus en
passe vraisemblablement de devenir
député européen de par rapport à ce qui
se passera d'ici la fin de l'année
je le vois mal s'éparpiller et allait
briguer des investitures de mairie donc
a pris au jeu il danse partout lanka on
sait pas donc a priori ça devrait aller
ça devait être évident votre investiture
en mars
je ne vais pas y avoir discussion selon
jimmy dans la vie comme disait mon père
il ya jamais que la mort qui soit sur ce
qui est par contre certain aujourd'hui
c'est que je suis maire demain je ne
sais pas si je serai à nouveau ce qui
est également certain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je suis candidat à ma
réélection
on va conclure rappelons plaisir avec
quelques mots sur l'actualité politique
toujours mais au sein du grand ensemble
époux bas payés en chance jean marc
marti s'en faisait l'écho tout à leurs
dons dans son éditorial là bas ce matin
donc il ya des tensions au sein de la
majorité à la collectivité territoriale
et même au sein de ba pays en chansons
on a vu donc des tensions entre
notamment yan monplaisir votre frère un
premier vice président de l'assemblée de
la ctm et miguel laventure conseiller
exécutif
alors écoutez qu'est ce que vous en
dites je t elle est portée sur les fonts
de ici c'est moi qui ai toujours si
c'est une grand semblait pumba payant
c'est moi qui suis à l'origine c'est à
dire ça s'est su ça ça on le sait
roger lise claude lise et mari alfred
marie-jeanne le disent ouvertement donc
oui je suis à l'origine et ça me fait
mal de voir un petit peu ce qui se passe
mais par contre vous savez c'est ça fait
partie de la d2 la vie démocratique ça
fait partie des aléas d'une vie et les
il est normal que s'il y est il y a des
façons d'agir ou de pensée différentes
entre des personnes
on se le dise mais il vaut mieux se le
dire parce qu'il n'y a rien de pire que
d'avoir des choses qui sont en dessous
quoi qu'on ressent et en dépit contredit
par oui donc ça c'est dit et ça se passe
très bien entre half entre miguel
laventure yan monplaisir ça se passe
très bien
non non non ils ont chacun simplement
leurs idées mais ils se parlent très
bien merci râle font plaisir bonne
journée merci